people
[Music]
thank you
we're Fierce champions of democratic
debate Free Speech but with that comes
the need to create an impartial
organization I've made decisions
based on a real passion about what the
BBC is and it's difficult when you work
for a public Institution
they need to control their image and
it's it's hard to
I mean differentiate between somebody's
personal views and and the corporations
views so I understand they want to try
and control what people say on social
media because it doesn't represent the
house View
[Music]
it's outrageous uh
the expression and opinion
it was entitled to his Free Speech you
know outside his job and he didn't do it
during the show
[Music]
impartially by caving in to Tory MPS who
are complaining about Gary lineker
they've got this one badly wrong and now
they're very very exposed as is the
government because at the heart of this
is the government's failure on the
Asylum system and rather than take
responsibility for the mess they've made
the government is casting around to
blame anybody else
[Music]
thank you
foreign